welcome everyone uh to this session
where we're gonna
see how we can emulate a Game Boy
using.net6 in c-sharp in this case
um it's gonna be a wild ride because I'm
gonna take you all back first into the
dusty Hardware manual and explain how
the thing works because you need to know
how the hardware Works before you can
emulate it in software
but before I start you can't talk about
a Game Boy without doing this one
um and a little bit about myself so my
name is Wesley I'm a coding architect at
experience in Belgium
um try not to spend too much of my
hard-earned money on retro gaming
consoles but I fail because I recently
just also bought a Nintendo a classic
one not a small one but the actual units
I also love to play around with
technology soldering stuff and finding
out how things work
um that's sort of when I was very young
much to the
yeah my parents didn't like this because
I basically took apart every radio that
I could find and then try to put it back
together and sometimes it worked mostly
it doesn't
so we have to buy a lot of radios when I
was young
now I have to give some credits first
because some of the people here that
visit NEC London might have seen the
talk similar like this one because when
I saw David Whitney's session on the
same topic
I got inspired to do this as well to
give give this a stab of my own
but I also saw on YouTube another
session by Michael Style
who really goes in depth about the
hardware of the Game Boy and these
sessions are amazing to see
um if you if you get the slides
afterwards all the links are in there as
well
but this there's like a whole series of
the ultimates something something talk
so I do recommend this one if you're
into Game Boy
um there's also one about the Atari I
think about the Commodore 64. great
talks you must see them if you're into
the rich people stuff
now as I mentioned I saw these sessions
especially the one from David and I
thought
now this sounds like a very fun project
to spend my time on
so
um I got into the Google
I searched for some Hardware material
and I found the original documents from
I think it was for Nintendo in America
to have them create games as well
so let's first dive in into the hardware
specifications of the dmg01 or the dot
matrix Game Boy
if you've never seen one
then this is the unit what it looks like
um
this is what it looks like in real life
still a good decent thing still works
after all these years amazing stuff
and it has a very very powerful 8-bit
sharp sm83 CPU that runs at 4.19
megahertz
not gigahertz not even close
but not really and I'll tell you later
why
it has a whopping eight kilobytes of
work memory and also eight kilobytes of
video memory
it has also a boot ROM to start up the
Game Boy which is 256 bytes
a nice tall 2.6 inch LCD screen with
four colors and a resolution of 160 by
144.
um yeah that's
not even
one fourth of HD but it worked at that
time
and for audio we have four channels two
pulse waves one noise and one wave
sample
if you open it up
I don't recommend it but if you do
this is what it looks like inside
so we have
let me try to
I have to wake this thing up
hello yes that's the CPU
and then we have the memory chip here
and then the video RAM over there
and if we look inside the CPU
it's actually a system on the chip
so the CPU the the DMG CPUs actually is
sharp and I'm going to read this because
I can't remember that one lr35902
um
that's why we refer to it as a DMG CPU
but it is a system on a chip and it has
multiple items it has the actual CPU
which is the sharp sm83
it has the ROM the boot ROM an audio
processing unit and a picture processing
unit
now the system alone if you would power
it on without one of these it's not
going to do a lot it's just going to
show you a blank line a blank block
so you have to put in a cartridge which
looks if you open it up again like this
somewhat like this there are multiple
variants of these
um why because the earliest cost
cartridges
only had the ROM inside so the ROM
contains your game the game boots and
then you you start playing it
but that only works with games that are
maximum have a maximum size of 32
kilobytes which is not a lot
if you want to have more
enhanced games like the Pokemon series
you need bigger cartridges but the
problem is that the Game Boy can only
address 32 kilobytes of ROM in this
cartridge so clever trick that they used
to do in the in the days they swap out
memory banks with something called a
memory uh
Bank controller chip which is
oop that tiny one over there
and then in this case you can also see
that it has a battery inside
which allowed you to save your games so
it had a ram chip inside as well and
then the battery is used to give it a
low power state so that if you turn up
the Game Boy it still holds that memory
for you so that years later even you can
still continue playing your games
some of the most advanced cartridges
even had a real-time clock inside which
used the battery as well so that your
Pokemon could evolve even if the Game
Boy was offline well shut down
now
this is about the hardware so the games
if you're going to emulate those we're
just gonna
download a ROM you're not supposed to do
that
so what you can do instead
because I want to make sure that
Nintendo is happy with me
you get the cartridge
like this
and you get magic do that
and then you can plug
this device in this even has a USBC
connection and then you can dump this
cartridge onto your system that's the
legal way of emulating games
but I'm sure you can find other ways as
well
um
so we have our games now we have to
build our system
and let's start by building the most
important part of our system which is
the CPU
and the CPU is the sm83 and it's heavily
based on a chip from 1974. which was way
back before the game boy also released
because the Game Boy only came out in
and it was based heavily on the Intel
8080 CPU which was well known at the
time everyone every developer knew this
CPU could program against it mostly in
assembly but they knew how it works
and then
a little bit later in 1976.
the xylog z80 was released and if you
remember if you were there at the time I
wasn't
um I'm not that old
um then
um that chip was really really popular
because it actually took the Intel 8080
and it added another set of CPU
registers
basically doubling the power of this of
the thing
while being completely backwards
compatible with the Intel 8080 so every
developer back then could program
immediately for this CPU as well and
then learn how to improve their
knowledge at the same time
the CPU was so so popular that it was
actually used in things like Roland
Jupiter 8 synthesizers and also the
Pac-Man arcade cabinets so really really
popular CPU at the time and very
powerful
so this should have been a perfect
candidate for our Game Boy
so Nintendo decided to contact sharp to
make something else
again
heavily based on both the Intel 8080 and
the xylock set 80. but also a little bit
different
why is it different
because this one has only the registers
from the Intel 8080 it doesn't have the
double set of registers to keep the
costs down
but Nintendo and sharp said there are
some really really good instructions
available in the z80 that the Intel 8080
just doesn't have so let's borrow these
instructions as well
and then they added some extra
instructions that doesn't exist in the
original CPUs mostly for looping inside
High memory
now when I talk about these registers
these are the ones that we have so it's
not a lot to work with and these days we
have a lot more registers these are all
only 8 bit wide so you can store numbers
in these ranging from zero to 255 or
-128 to 127
and you have the a register the
accumulator one the F for flags and then
we have b c d e for General data or
addresses HL mostly used for addresses
and of course a program counter
which points to the next instruction
that the CPU is going to execute and a
stack pointer to point to the stack
space in memory
and for Flags
those are typically used if you don't
know to keep track of State in the CPU
while performing instructions
and in this case we only have actually
Four Flags which is also not a lot
compared to other CPUs but the most
important ones are there called the the
Z the zero flag
which is set to one whenever an
operation results in a zero result
typically used as a precondition to jump
after comparison comparison
we have the N flag which is the called
the negative flag
but
you might think it's going to be set
when something becomes negative but in
this case it's actually being set if you
perform a negative instruction like a
decrement or a subtraction so it's a bit
different
and then we also have H and which is a
half carry flag used for a decimal
addition which is a pain to emulate and
then the carry flag if you go over your
8-bit values then you have to set the
carrier flag as well because your result
became larger than 255.
okay these are the basics for our CPU
then let's see how can we get something
on the screen
so the picture processing units is
heavily based on the one that they used
in this device the Nintendo
Entertainment System
because huge popular console in both
Japan America and Europe so they know
how this works and said let's use that
one as well that system in the Game Boy
as well
and when they put it in the game boy
because they don't have that much power
to work with and it also needs to run on
four batteries instead of on AC power
they only they had to limit the
capabilities of the picture processing
units which results in only having four
Shades of Gray
but because the screen is a green
original originally a greenish LCD you
get these lovely shades of green instead
and then whenever you want to put
something on the screen
everything that you want to show has to
be organized in little tiles that are
eight by eight pixels in size
and everything also needs to fit in the
memory in that eight kilobytes of memory
if you go over it won't show up on the
screen
and here you can see an example
of the tile set
for a particular game and anyone has a
clue which game this is
three
yeah it is Tetris
you can
kind of make out
the the parts of those dancing people at
the end
if you've never seen the dancing people
you ended up a Finnish Tetris
um and you can see here as well if you
want to show if you want to display text
on the Game Boy you have to include your
own fonts so there's no funds inside you
have to do everything yourself
so that's one our tiles
but then how do we get something on the
screen and that happens in different
layers
so we have a background layer
where which is 256 pixels large in in
square
which is 32 tiles and we can only show
on our LCD 166 by 144 so our background
is larger than we can display
so what we do we set a viewport
using two registers the screen registers
we can say we want to only display a
part of that big background map
and that results then in the screen that
we see on the right
and then you can see there's a a white
area at the bottom and in this case in
this game Super Mario Land 2 that's used
to fill in with status effects so
this is called the window layer
typically used to get
status on the screen like number of
lives remaining in this case you can
also see the amount of coins that you
gathered amount of enemies that you've
vanquished and then the amount of time
left in the level
in some games like tennis the windows
layer was used window layer was used to
pop up Mario in the top of the screen
saying that you went out of bounds or
when it's dues then Mario popped up
inside juice
but with these two layers alone it's not
going to be a very fun game because
nothing's moving
in the next slide nothing's moving as
well because I didn't include a video
but we'll get to that later
but we have to add some Sprites as well
because Sprites are the thing things
that move around on the screen
um
and
these can only have three colors
instead of four because the fourth one
is transparent
and you can only display up to 40
Sprites in the entire screen at the same
time
and of those 40 you can only have 10 on
One scan line and a scan line is one
pixel in Heights so it could happen if
you have a very busy game that you get
some flickering effects because there's
too many going on too many things going
on with the same line
um so a lot of
times they just decided if there's nine
items on a certain area then they don't
draw the 10th one
what also happens typically is if you
see in this game for example the coins
that you can pick up as Mario
are not Sprites
because if you have a lot of coins to to
pick up it would have a heavy impact on
the number of enemies that you can also
display at the same time so coins in
this case are typically part of the
background layer and then once you hit
them the background layer gets updated
so that that coin is removed
it's a neat little trick that you had to
do as a developer to get stuff working
on this thing
that's our picture processing unit
let's now see what we can do audio wise
so as I mentioned we have four channels
the first two are similar so the first
two are pulse wave channels and they
do the typical old computer sounds
um and the first channel of these is
typically used for special effects so if
you pick up a coin or something that one
gets used to play that coin sound
which also means that your music is
going to be a little bit different
because you're missing one of the
channels
um the reason why the first one is used
for sound effects is because it also is
the only Channel that's capable of
producing more sweep like effects to get
like phaser shots or space sound effects
things
um now if we have a listen to one of
these
if it wants
[Music]
this is what it sounds like
the next channel is the noise Channel
and noise channel is if you have a very
old television set and you have no cable
connection to it or the antenna failed
or something you get like this nice
snowy screen and then it was like a
oh
effect for people on YouTube that was me
not your connection failing and this
channel this noise effect channel is
typically used for percussion or
explosion effects
in this case we get a nice March drum
well knife
we have to do
we had to use whatever we could use to
make some sound out of this
and then the fourth channel is a wave
Channel and this one is a bit special
because if I talk about waveforms as a
from a music producer point of view
think of this as the Sawtooth the square
wave triangle wave things you can also
just draw yourself and then reuse to
form some music
some people went really far with this
and actually created voice samples which
is on the Game Boy as well I think you
can
again heavily used in Pokemon for
Pikachu for example in this case it's
more like a buzzy sound that you're
getting
and then if you combine the four
channels together
you get a lovely sound
[Music]
and some of you might know this music as
well from Pokemon
okay so we have our CPU we have our
picture processing unit and our audio
processing unit
but these things need to work together
and in modern CPUs we have like
interrupts and I O ports so you can
easily say to your video card hey you
need to do this or to your send card you
have to play this
but the game mode is a very simple
system
which uses memory mapped i o which means
that in that address space of 64
kilobytes because it has a 16 bit
address bus
it has to be able to address everything
which means in this case our first 16
kilobytes typically points to the ROM
Bank zero of your game cartridge and the
next Bank next 16 kilobytes goes to bank
one up to FF or 255 using that
controller switch
then we
get the address space for our video ramp
external RAM which lives on the
cartridge so that's holding your saves
and then the work memory as well
then there's a section called Echo Ram
which is a bit special it was actually
not used but because how the hardware is
created it maps to other spaces of the
Game Boy hardware and it copies well it
doesn't copy but it if you address that
memory space you actually get data from
another address space
it's not supposed to be used but people
actually use it anyway and sometimes it
results in a crash
and and the final green bar
if we zoom in what's in there that holds
our Sprite table or object attribute map
the i o registers to interact with the
serial port to interact with the
joystick on the device and to interact
with the video and the APU
and then we also have something called
hyram which I will talk about later as
well and finally but not least the
interrupt enable register because if you
don't enable your interrupts nothing
will happen
okay we also know how to interact with
this thing
now if you fire up the Game Boy the
first thing that will run is that boot
run
and the boot ROM looks like this
it's a bit small but don't worry I'll
guide you through what happens here and
this is the actual original sorry
Nintendo source code for the assembly in
the boot ROM
it still amazes me how the community was
able to get this source code
it's a story that I've been uh told I
would like to believe it because it's so
awesome
someone opened up their Game Boy
it didn't work anymore I hope
and they desoldered the DMG CPU
took off the plastic cover until they
saw the actual die of the CPU zoomed in
with a microscope and then somehow
decided that must be the boot room
and that must be a one and that must be
a zero
and 256 times later this came out
some people do have way too much time on
their hands but here we are we have the
source code which is nice
now what happens is whenever you turn on
the Game Boy the first thing that we'll
run is a little loop at the top to empty
your memory address space
it will also set the stack pointer to
the first position
and then we have to initialize the sound
registers
because at some point what we're going
to do actually is we're going to scroll
down the Nintendo logo and then when
it's at the middle of the screen you get
that two times the bidding sound
so we also have to set up that Nintendo
logo
and that's actually stored here
the Nintendo logo so we also have to
decode it first
because
while it's stored over there
it's also stored in your cartridge
more about that in a second
so we're scrolling down that logo all
the way to the middle of the screen and
then you'll see that there's a gap
between the scrolling because right
before we hit that end of the screen
we're playing those two sounds
and then again here's the Nintendo logo
and we have to compare it with the logo
that's stored on your cartridge
because what happens if you decide to
not pay Nintendo a license and you want
to build games
you're legally not allowed then in that
case to use their logo
and if you don't use their logo your
game will stop
it will not work your Nintendo logo will
actually stop running here and will end
up in a loop so that your game never
starts
so you have to pay Nintendo license
include the logo on your cartridge and
if it matches exactly that the bootstrom
has stored as well then
it will continue it does also a little
checksum calculation at the end just to
make sure that the cartridge is fully
inserted so that you don't get cardboard
data later and a very bad game
experience and then the final step here
is to disable the boot room and then it
will switch that first 256 bytes with
the actual cartridge contents and start
up your game
all right
we know enough of the hardware
let's start actually okay
some things decided to pop up my screen
fine let's start emulating the game boy
and when you emulate a system any system
you typically start with the CPU
which means that we have to look for
some information about the CPU and the
instruction set of that CPU
and there's a nice person who put a nice
graphical table on the internet
containing all of the different
instructions and what they mean and what
they need
um but I noticed something on that web
page
it has Json
so what's inside of the Json file
well it has a list of op codes in this
case we have the zero X10 opcode and it
also has the the name of that opcode in
this case it's the stop instruction
It also says it's two bytes long which
takes four Cycles it has one upper end
it's an immediate instruction and so on
and so forth
now with all these instructions
we can then build a system that reads
this Json file translates it into
runnable code and then use that to
emulate our CPU
oh and by the way the stop instruction
is a bit special it actually halts your
program completely doesn't run anything
it's used to preserve power and then it
starts again your CPU whenever it
receives input so you can basically use
this whenever you're pausing the game
and then if you press start again then
it will continue and then start running
your CPU and Meanwhile your battery is
not
used that heavily in the system
all right
we have our op codes we have our Json
file let's start writing some code
and what is a CPU basically it's a
endless loop that runs the instructions
until they are no more instructions to
run or until you switch off the Game Boy
in this case our Game Boy power toggle
is a cancellation token so we can just
cancel the token and then that will stop
our CPU from running
um and again a CPU has a program counter
which is in the beginning set to zero
first instruction and it will every time
fetch the next instruction execute it
until we end somewhere
and what else is this execution thing
doing
well it's basically a gigantic list of
switch statements
at least in my first version of the code
where you look at that name of the
instruction for example the no operation
the stop halts disable interrupt enable
interrupt
in this case you can see not a lot was
implemented yet these are placeholders
but let's dive into some of the
instructions that I did implement but
before I do so note one thing here
um the nice if debug Intrigue because
I still had no video output I still had
no sound output I just set the CPU and I
needed to be able to see how it went so
I I'll put it every instruction that I
was about to run
not the best thing to do if you're
emulating a system because this slows
down the system to a crawl but for
debugging purposes that works just fine
so
these are the ones that I did Implement
at that stage mainly the load
instructions because you have to get
data from the cartridge in memory or
data from memory into another register
you have to be able to add data together
to subtract data to compare and some
stuff like that
and then if you look for example at the
load instruction
I was very very happy with my comments
back then
and then I have a load instruction does
nothing more than decide which is the
source of data which is the target of
the data and then move source to Target
that's it
because we're really working on the
hardware level here it's typically very
basic stuff that we're doing
and then in some cases you also have to
update your flags
so this was already quite an effort to
make that work to also get to this stage
um did it actually work uh
so I pressed F5 in Visual Studio
and I did find the boot ROM code so I
just said look
try to run this
and this was my console output
it started doing something
but was it doing the right thing
so if we look at the original code from
the boot ROM remember the first step was
initializing the ram
what we are doing here is you can see on
the left
is the console output so we're actually
doing exactly the same instruction
loading the stack pointer with the
highest address so we initial initialize
our stack pointer
then we xor The Edge register which
means it gets a zero inside
and then we load the HL register with
the top address of the memory chip
here in the assembly you get a jump
label address zero zero zero seven
on the left side we don't see that
because it's just executing code
and you'll see
you're loading that zero value in the
memory address HL
which is 9ff at this moment and then it
immediately decrements HL to 9ffe
that's one of those sm83 special
instructions to quickly Loop over
another space
it then Compares in the left part of the
HL register a certain bit to see did we
reach the end of the address space that
we want to clear if not then it jumps
back to the top and it keeps on
decrementing until it reaches that
bottom of the memory chip
and as you can see the loop was working
so it's actually doing the thing that
it's intended to do
so okay we have a first success
let's move on to the graphics
and
filled with enthusiasm after a few
nights of work
seeing that first console output as up
all right back to the hardcore manual I
start reading about the picture
processing unit and everything that's
related to it and then I found out that
I made a very very big mistake
uh well
you see I forgot about one special thing
called timing
uh yeah there's timing registers there's
timing interrupts there's the actual
Hardware timing that you need to emulate
if you want to actually
accurately emulate the device
um I'll go over this slide in a second
because I forgot to mention this in the
beginning
I did say that the CPU runs officially
at 4.90 megahertz but
these chips have special timings
and the memory chip
cannot work at 4.19 megahertz it
actually works four times as slow
so your CPU is banned to the speed of
your memory
there's a tiny crystal inside this
machine which generates pulse every one
megahertz
and when that pulse goes High
then some things can happen and then
that pulse goes low again
then it's safe to read data so this is
really on the hardware electronic level
that you need to work with a Game Boy
but also need to emulate the game boy
because
your CPU is not going to wait on your
graphics cards in this case
to say hey I've done painting continue
please
in this case that pulse sends a really
opposed to all the systems and they
react at this almost the same time
so when we are emulating we also need to
give every system
part a chance to react
and I was just thinking okay I have my
CPU and at some point my screen buffer
is filled
dump on the screen and go time but
that's not how this thing works
because
the Nintendo
uh sorry the Game Boy was based on the
Nintendo the the picture processing unit
which also means it was intended to work
on a crtc device an old television
and how does a CRT device work
it has an electron gun that shoots
electrodes electrons on the screen of
phosphorus screen which lights up the
right colors and it does that by really
going line per line all the way from top
to the bottom and then it goes all the
way back up to the top but it is not
perfect and it will not hit your screen
dimensions it will actually overshoot a
little bit first
at the top then also at the left and the
right sides it will not be perfect and
then at the bottom also you have like a
blank area where you don't have a
picture but you do have some time that
you're spending in there
and these areas are called
horizontal blank and vertical blank
and the game boy uses that same
information to also have phases where
you do something in your GPU
for example
before you paint the screen
there's a face called object attribute
memory search
which means before I'm going to draw
this line
you need to make sure that all the
Sprites of that line are in the correct
place in memory and that's your face oim
search
then when we hit our first pixel line
actual pixel that is going to be
displayed we're entering pixel transfer
mode where we transfer the pixels
prepared to the screen
and during this time nothing can change
so you can't jump at that moment as a
character enemies can't move because
they're fixed in that location
and then at the end when we're done
drawing
we have a face age blank called and then
that can be used to update the time in
the level update the score update the
sound and something else
um
during these times a lot of the data and
registers are locked so that you can't
change them which is why we have that
high Ram the small area in the memory
map register because this is the time
where you can only use high ramp to Loop
over stuff
now
after reading all of this information in
the manual it's quite a heavy manual I
was thinking my God that's a lot of
process
this is really not the place where I
want to be in because I was thinking
this is a fun hobby project not a one
that's going to consume months and
months of my time
so it's time to look for a solution
um and yeah there's not really a market
for emulating a Game Boy so there's not
to be not a lot to be found on stack
overflow but luckily
there was this person that did the same
session David Whitney and he published
his Source codes on GitHub
so
I looked at the source code I found out
it also mentions it's also mentioned
during his session it was based on a
Java emulator basically he ported it
to.net core 3.1
so I said
in that moment let's go over to.net6
because it's new and fancy
and also added Sun support because David
tried some stuff didn't get it to work I
took another stab at it
and somehow managed to make it work in
the end
a lot of things were already there but
the actual sound driver for Windows was
missing
and also found a little bug in one of
the channels that was already existing
in the Java version and also fixed that
one at the same time
and also the version that David made
with Windows forms
had a little bit of a timing issue
especially when you start adding sound
it really slowed down the game so I
redid how the
how the picture Processing Unit works on
the screen in Windows forms so that it
could run a bit faster
so
okay
let's try to run a game and
okay we get the title screen we get
sound in this case you can't hear the
sound because it's a image but
we got something resulting in here and
then I wanted to play Tetris I pressed
start
and nothing happened
so that was really strange I couldn't
even move the cursor to two player
nothing did anything up the sound was
playing the demo of the three started
playing so the game was running fine it
just didn't accept any inputs
huh that's weird how can we debug this
well the first thing that you can try is
just load another game
so I loaded up Super Mario Land
um
again title screen I press start it
started working I could play Super Mario
Land just fine
so why did Tetris not work
no that means that we have to somehow
set the breakpoint
in our CPU to find out why it's not
really reacting the way it should
but yeah this is assembly land so
that means that we're gonna have to step
through a lot of up codes
for example
if you look at that same simple Loop in
the beginning
this is clearing eight kilobytes of
memory which is
8192 memory addresses
this tiny little Loop of six
instructions
would already take you
um
about 24 000 steps to debug
yeah
that's not gonna work
I'm gonna wait around for that one I'll
grow a beard and trust me when I say
that I don't easily grow a beard
so that's not really
how we're gonna wait how we're gonna be
able to debug this game in this case you
have to rely on your knowledge really
and
I happen to know Tetris I used to play
that game a lot when I was a kid and I
remembered
if you had two game boys or a friend
with the Game Boy
and if you had a friend
and a Link cable and both of you had the
same game
you could fire up those game boys and
play Tetris against each other using
that Link cable
so to know that there are two players
there must be some form of communication
already happening when you start the
game
to know that you can play against
someone else or only can play alone
so maybe that's why Tetris doesn't work
aha that's it
so
again I went back to the manual
and the manual has a nice flowchart
about the serial communication part
oh wait that doesn't work I have to edit
this one
so it actually says what happens when
you communicate with a Serial device I
had another look at the code and saw
that one of the registers were not being
said correctly
swap some bits around and then complete
address
all right cool we made it work
so what's next because you never end
right
well a few years after the game boy was
released
the next version came out with a little
bit more colors than only four
so we I want to really add the Game Boy
Color support it's already partially in
there but it's most of the games Crash
and you're also supposed to be able to
play normal games old games in color
mode that also really doesn't work
so I want to make sure that that works
and there's also
there's two GitHub repositories at the
time that I made the slides one of them
might be done now but some people made
unit tests for the Game Boy
so there are people that made custom
roms to test specific aspects of the
hardware of the Game Boy to see if your
emulator emulates them well
really cool
and I want to make sure that all of them
run as well
what I also want to do and I also
already tried to but didn't get a
success yet
is to make a Blazer version of this
because why not make a wasm that you can
integrate your Gameboy emulator and run
it everywhere would be cool
um it's not there yet because I can't
make it work without threading support
and in Blazer in.net6 Blazers trading
support was not a thing
it's supposed to be added in.net7 I
didn't have a look at might take a stab
later today who knows
but
um I have 15 minutes left and I didn't
show you the emulator which is a shame
so it's time to actually look at the
damn thing
and
show you that it works
and we have
Visual Studio
I press Ctrl F5 and let's open up a
classic
this is also something you're not
supposed to do
you're not supposed to show the Nintendo
logo but because that means you're
emulating Nintendo's copyrighted
software
could be a little bit late to ask but is
there someone from Nintendo in the room
okay cool and you see your video might
be pulled from YouTube after this one uh
we'll see how that happens but you can
just play the game
and you can watch me play Super Mario
foreign
because it's an emulator you can play
around with the sound as well let me
actually first
go back to the Overworld so that's a bit
more
fun
you can
disable some of the channels
so that it sounds
you can now find out how the Sound Works
and then you know you have the drum
sample and the bass is away from it
and then you can turn them back on
all right come on
[Music]
voila there we go we have our film music
I am going to disable that boost one for
now because I want to run one more game
which is a very special game
it's the NDC London game
not not really a game it's just big Ben
and The Clash playing long and calling
if there depends from The Clash I do
apologize it's only an 8-bit version of
the song
I have to do I can only do so much with
8-bits
uh but I just wanted to show there's
there's still a very active Community
around the Game Boy
um playing well playing around with
making their own games there's even
someone who created a Unity like Studio
where you can build games with uh code
elements like in scratch if you know
scratch you can easily script your game
very cool
it also outputs the original well
original it outputs a c version so you
can go further and see if you want to
and there's also like a Tracker music
software which you can use to make music
for the Game Boy which is what I used to
make this uh music as well
this is actually also Community using
the Gameboy itself with something called
little sound DJ a game for the Game Boy
and then going live on stage DJing and
playing music from The Game Boy which is
awesome
um but I also still have some time so I
can dive into the code a little bit
let me zoom in just a pad here
so this is the main Loop of the Game Boy
when you fire it up you still have that
cancellation token which is going to
keep on running until you switch off the
game or start a new ROM
and then
every
time you go through the loop you do a
tick
which is that Crystal generating a pulse
to all the systems inside the hardware
and then after a tick happens you might
need to enable or disable the screen
and in oh sorry that was a bit too much
and inside that tick what what happens
is well no it's a bit small
there we go
you either do high dma transfer or you
do a CPU event
then you update your timer you update
your other direct memory access you
update your sound you update your zero
port and you update your screen
so everything gets a chance to run
that's really important what's also
important which is also a big mistake
that I made in the first time
if your CPU gets the chance
to perform something
which is What's Happening Here
that doesn't necessarily mean that it
will my first version did this
I read an instruction
that instruction might need other data
and even more data so I read this this
this and this
execute the instruction and then my CPU
tick was done
wrong completely wrong what you need to
do is if you access memory
that means that you had to wait on the
clock
or the tick rather to go up or down
because you need to wait until it's safe
to read that actual memory
which means then you need to give the
rest of the system a chance to run
before you can do the next step which
might be fetching another piece of
memory waiting again and then you can
execute the actual instruction
so it's a bit more elaborate to make it
really really work
but uh
in this case it is keeping track of all
of this also a little experiment to see
which one is faster is it the for Loop
or is it the while true
doesn't really matter because it's
compiled down to the same thing
but here you can see it's fetching the
up codes
and then fetching in some cases two up
codes
fetching the operands and then only then
it's running the actual instruction
and I must say the original source code
from the Java version
was pretty well structured because it
basically adds all of the instructions
for example you get here register a load
command which is a one of the LD
instructions and then you get two
operands or you get a jump or you get an
ad and then
it's really really nicely structured so
that it all ties in together and you get
small pieces that you can understand how
they work together which is really cool
and then your GPU again has those state
where you go
OEM search
pixel trans wait I have to do this you
push all the way around OEM search pixel
transfer and then age blank and then at
the bottom get V blank
so you have those modes here as well
and then you start executing
where is it here
so if you're inside a specific phase OEM
search and so forth and so on you
execute that face until you hit a switch
in state and then you swap your modes
and phases around so that every phase
gets to work and then for example the
pixel transfer really is nothing more
than
filling a buffer with the pixels from
the correct memory spaces so that your
windows horns gets a chance to Output
the video on screen
um yeah
I could go
probably another four hours talking
about the code
but uh I only have eight minutes no
seven minutes left so I'm gonna give you
a chance to ask me some questions if you
have any
how many hours have I spent working on
this way too much
I can try to look in the git repository
I started with the best step get ignore
um
and then
to get
somewhere workable is live in July
no sorry 13 October
so that was a good month and a half
but also a lot of restless nights
because at some point
um I actually think it's in here
1 25 am
that might be my yeah it was still
manageable 1 25 am was the last latest
at night that I was working on this
before I realized maybe it's time to go
to bed now
um but yeah I've spent
several several hours in this if I would
total it up it's going to be easily
uh four or five full-time weeks
and that's with a working example
because what I did forget to mention is
I did not just clone David's repository
but I put it next to mine and then
compared what I was missing and doing
wrong and then
I did copy it over manually but also
manually because then I forced myself to
understand what was happening in the
code base rather than just saying Fork
it and improve it
because it's a bit different than what
David is doing I did send him a pull
request for adding sound in this version
as well
um
so to help him his improve his version
as well
no other questions
that's a bit of a niche topic not
everyone is probably waiting to jump in
and writing an emulator themselves but I
must say I had a lot of fun trying to do
something like this
I sometimes get crazy ideas to to do
stuff one of the other ideas is
I started porting Doom to c-sharp
also got that running it also runs on
Maui Doom so we have Doom running on a
Android phone using c-sharp which is
cool
okay so if there's no other questions
then I have one more slide
[Music]
thank you
and if you want to grab the presentation
which includes all of the links to
materials also includes links to how to
make your own Game Boy games and stuff
then you can find this QR code but I'm
sure we'll also get the slides at Via
indices back to you later as well all
right thank you and have a great rest of
the conference